[Music]
in 2016
Johnny Depp was accused of domestic
violence and fans were not pleased to
see that he was going to be part of
fantastic beasts and where to find them
but then when Warner Brothers confirms
that he was going to play Gilbert
Grindelwald in fantastic beasts the
crimes of Grindelwald they were shocked
why couldn't they replace him here's
everything you need to know about this
controversy including what JK Rowling
has to say about this if you love
fantastic beasts as much as we do don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up to see more
stories like this today we are talking
about the controversy surrounding
fantastic beasts the crimes of
Grindelwald the accusations after
meeting in 2009 and dating since 2012
Johnny Depp and Amber Heard got married
in 2015 but it didn't take long for them
to split up as they filed for divorce
one year after and amber was granted a
temporary restraining order against
death forcing him to stay at least 100
yards away from her and avoid any
contact with her she feared that he
would come back to terrorize her
physically and emotionally according to
her the actor had been violent for quite
some time as he had been injured in 2015
after punching a wall when they were
arguing she also said that she feared
for her life in December 2015 and
published a picture with a mark on her
eye and a cut on her lip a witness also
reported that they heard the couple
fighting over the phone when Johnny
threw a cell phone at amber space
someone called 9-1-1 but the police said
that they found no evidence of a crime
some text messages between amber and
Depp's assistants were also published to
show that he knew what was happening and
we also saw a leaked video of depth
throwing a wine bottle and being
aggressive with amber these are only
some of the proofs that Amber Heard had
against Johnny Depp when she accused him
of domestic violence Johnny Depp's side
of the story after the divorce
Johnny Depp's representant released a
statement to tell people that the actor
will not respond to any of the salacious
false stories gossip misinformation and
lies about his personal life his
daughters and his exes Vanessa Paradis
and loriann Allison also defended him in
the
as the actor had never been violent with
them amber was accused of doing this for
the money and this is why she retracted
her request for temporary spousal
support as she thought that it was a
standard operating procedure in a
divorce case but the situation got worse
for the actress when she appeared to be
manic and irrational during her
deposition according to the actor's
lawyer no matter what the divorce case
was finally settled and the restraining
order against Johnny Depp was withdrawn
the couple said in a joint statement
that their relationship was intensely
passionate and at times volatile but
always bound by love neither party has
made false accusations for financial
gains and to prove it the actress said
that she would give the money that she
earned from the divorce to charity no
one knows if he was guilty or not the
two actors simply decided to make an
agreement and Amber Heard has decided to
move on to something else no one is sure
of anything and only the two actors know
what really happened the controversy
during the first movie Johnny Depp had
already been working on fantastic beasts
and where to find them before he was
part of this tragic controversy this is
why we understand why it was hard to
replace this actor but didn't stop some
fans from criticizing this choice
however everyone who worked on the first
fantastic beasts movie defended the
actor JK Rowling said that she was
delighted to see Johnny Depp play
Gelbart Grindelwald as he's done
incredible things with that character
director David Yates also said that fans
had to trust them and see what he does
in the movie you won't see very much in
this movie because he appears in it very
fleetingly he appears much more in the
second movie what you have to remember
about Johnny is that extraordinary
talent and that talent never goes away
Hollywood is such a fickle place people
go up and go down Yeats also added when
talking about death he's a huge potter
fan he loves the world he's beyond
excited about working on this material
in fact he didn't even want to see a
script he just said I'm in David Heyman
the executive producer also added that
here's the thing misogyny abuse
maltreatment of people is unacceptable
but none of us know what happened in
that room this is why he thinks that he
would be unfair for anyone to be the
judge and the jury what the director had
to say Harry Potter fans forgive the
team for letting Johnny Depp be part of
the first fantastic beasts movie but
then many of them were shocked to see
he was still going to be part of
fantastic beasts the crimes of
Grindelwald as he hasn't been replaced
this is why David Yates had to open up
about this once again he told
Entertainment Weekly honestly there's an
issue at the moment where there's a lot
of people being accused of things
they're being accused by multiple
victims and it's compelling and
frightening with Johnny it seems to me
there was one person who took a pop at
him and claimed something he then talked
about the man he sees every day who is
full of decency and kindness and that's
all he sees he said that whatever
accusation was out there it doesn't
tally with the kind of human being that
he has been working with and he's not
the only one as some of the women in
depths life have said the same thing
that's not the human being we know
usually there are multiple accusers over
many years that need to be examined but
that's not the case for the actor he is
not in this category in any shape or
form this is why director David Yates
simply concluded that it's a dead issue
what JK Rowling thinks the author and
screenwriter is one of the women that
Potterheads admired the most in the
world this is why many of them turned to
her because they wanted to know what she
thought about this a fan tweeted so if I
understand correctly the actor who
played Crabbe a minor character was
fired from Harry Potter for doing drugs
yet Johnny Depp who abused his wife gets
a major role in your movies correct me
if I'm wrong ad JK underscore Rowling
this young woman absolutely wasn't shy
but it wasn't me neither
she didn't expect any answer from the
writer but she was shocked when she saw
that JK Rowling blocked her on Twitter
we know that the writer did criticize
men accused of assault when she
suggested that men like Harvey Weinstein
were too dangerous to be at liberty but
this time she simply ignored the
elephant in the room and rejected her
fans this is probably the worst answer
this fan could ever get but what do you
think about this controversy do you
think that Johnny Depp still deserves
the chance to play The Dark Wizard in
fantastic beasts the crimes of
Grindelwald since no one knows if he was
guilty or not or do you think that any
accusations should be taken more
seriously don't be shy to share your
thoughts in the comment section down
below we love to hear what you think and
that's it for the controversy
surrounding fantastic beasts the crimes
of Grindelwald for more stories like
this make sure you watch ten disturbing
real stories behind Disney fairy tales
thanks
watching and see you next time
[Music]